what do drones infertility and the CIA
have in common
polio yes the virus that was almost
totally eradicated a few years ago is
now being called a public health
emergency by the World Health
Organization what happened I'm Francesca
and here are five facts you need to know
about polios comeback polio is a super
contagious virus that is most
threatening to children under five once
you catch it usually through
contaminated food or water
the virus invades the nervous system
causing paralysis and sometimes death at
its height in the 1950s the virus killed
half a million people a year globally 66
thousand in the United States alone but
in 1957 American scientist Jonas Salk
introduced a vaccine and 20 years later
there were no new cases in the US by
2003 a global eradication campaign had
eliminated new cases by 99.8% but in the
past couple of years
holy-o's been researching
Oh leo was never actually eradicated in
Pakistan Afghanistan and Nigeria new
cases have popped up in 2014 in Cameroon
Equatorial Guinea Ethiopia Iraq Syria
Somalia and the West Bank in Gaza but
why cause they're places that have seen
a lot of conflict
for example the Syrian civil war has led
to the collapse of the health care
system and forced 9 million people to
live in poor sanitary conditions the
result a polio outbreak and to make
matters worse there are now cases of
polio in neighboring Iraq cultural
misconceptions also play a part in the
polio comeback back in 2003 Islamic
leaders in northern Nigeria stopped
vaccinations because they thought it was
a Western conspiracy to sterilize Muslim
women a similar thing happened in 2007
in Pakistan when the head of the polio
eradication effort was assassinated
after rumors started that the
vaccination campaign was also a
sterilization plot then in February of
2013 Boko Haram killed at least nine
polio workers in northern Nigeria this
kind of violence has made it hard for
vaccinations to continue though health
care workers keep trying
under the obama administration the CIA
used a fake polio immunization campaign
to get Osama bin Laden's family DNA come
again
yep though it's never been concerned or
denied if the DNA is what led us Navy
SEALs to raid bin Laden's compound still
close to 70 public health workers have
been murdered on suspicion of their
involvement now Pakistan has the worst
polio problem in the world with a vast
majority of cases and the u.s. promises
never to use fake vaccinations as a CIA
cover again some of the most lawless
regions of Pakistan are also the biggest
havens for polio in Waziristan a Taliban
stronghold close to 300,000 children
haven't been vaccinated Taliban leaders
refused to let health care workers in
for fear that they are spying on their
activities and targeting the area for
drones they've said if the drone program
stops they'll let the vaccinations begin
so far this year there have only been 89
polio cases reported but last year there
were only 45 that's almost double and if
the virus continues to spread we could
be looking at 200,000 new cases per year
within a decade what do you think how
many more countries will polio spread to
before this global health emergency is
stopped